i want to talk about axial precession
which is a complicated thing and it
involves rotating objects so axial
procession is where you've got an object
which
is spinning and whenever you've got a
spinning object there's this strange
effect that when you try to twist it one
way or the other it never quite the axis
it's processing the axis it's rotating
about never moves in the direction
you're expecting it to and in fact
generally starts to move around like
that
here's the earth which looks like a
perfect sphere only it's not and it's
rotating and we hope we've got it the
right way around this time
i'm also going to be talking about a
gyroscope if i were to take this
gyroscope and just leave it there it's
quite well balanced and if i rotate it
around and it stays where it is
if it's perfectly balanced nothing moves
and now
just let me move this thing this extra
weight so this is unbalanced
and then you can see the effect of
changing the balance if i put it there
this will drop down it will oscillate in
a very simple minded way just like a
pendulum
so now let me rotate this and everybody
seeing this will imagine that the effect
of
rotation is just to let this drop down
but it doesn't do that
it doesn't do that at all this motion
round is called precession it precesses
around this axis so i'm going to call it
axial
precession
and you can see that it's rotating
around at a finite
rate
which is fairly slow but if i made this
come further out and put more force on
it it would go a little bit faster so
this is an effect due to the fact oops
that this is trying to push it downwards
but as it's trying to push it downwards
with no counter balancing force on the
other side
it actually goes the other way it starts
spinning that way the trouble is you
tend to look at a spinning object and
think of it as just kind of
a single entity and actually of course
what's going on is there's different
bits of it that are all actually moving
around in a circle so it's actually
quite a complicated system here of
different bits all rotating around and
really when you try and then change the
orientation of the thing you're trying
to change a whole bunch of different
objects and make them all move to
different places and move in different
directions well the direction it rotates
in depends on whether i make it go that
way or the other way so if i spun it the
other way it would if i got it the other
way i probably got it the same way i got
it go the other way
then it will rotate
backwards so the direction of this
rotation has a big effect if it goes the
other way it will process in the
opposite direction
so the question then is is there any
effect like that on the earth
so if i take this sphere one question
that arose early on is because of the
spinning of the earth is it
squashed at the poles
and fatter at the equator or is it
elongated the poles a prolate ellipsoid
they call it and narrow it
and people really didn't know the answer
to this rene descartes predicted that it
was going to be fatter at the poles
whereas newton worked out that a
spinning object would be fatter at the
equator the french academy of sciences
in 1715 sent an expedition to peru
somewhere over
here
near the equator and to lapland
somewhere up there near the pole to see
if there was a difference
and they came back
did the experiment over 10 years and
worked out it was fatter at the equator
in other words the earth is not
as it's here but it's got a bit of blue
tack an extra bit of bulge around the
equator if you have a perfectly
spherical spinning object then it won't
actually process at all because there's
really no difference as you as you
reorient it it doesn't really change at
all but because the earth is slightly
oblate it's slightly squashed
that means that if you reorient it
you're actually kind of changing the
configuration of the whole earth and so
the earth is a spinning non-spherical
object and that means that when you try
and twist it the axis that it's rotating
about will start to process around so
because it's spinning it doesn't want to
go that way it wants to waggle around
very slowly like this this is called the
axial procession of the earth now that
is quite amazing but even more amazing
is the fact that
there was a greek guy who in about 120
bc
measured it newton was the one who
actually understood what the effect was
but in fact the measurement of the
effect the measurement of this
procession goes back much further than
that there's some argument about who the
first person who actually made the
measurement uh actually was but it seems
likely that one of the first reliable
measurements was actually hipparchus in
about 150 bc
um who did this very clever thing of
measuring the positions of the stars
relative to the sun at a particular on a
particular date and then compared them
to previous measurements that had
already been made and showed that
actually on that date the stars weren't
in the same position relative to the sun
it's a bit of a tricky one because of
course you want to measure the position
of stars relative to the sun but of
course if you want to see the stars the
sun's not usually around because you see
stars at night and if you want to see
the sun stars aren't usually around
because you can't see the stars during
the day
so but he had this very elegant way of
doing it which was that he waited for a
lunar eclipse which is when the earth
comes between the sun and the moon and
and so when there's a lunar eclipse you
know that these three planets are
exactly in a line sorry two planets and
the sun are exactly in a line and that
means if the moon's over there you know
that the sun has to be 180 degrees away
in completely the opposite direction so
what he do is waited for this lunar
eclipse then measured the positions of
stars relative to the moon and then just
added 180 degrees to his measurement and
that told him how far that star was away
from the sun on the sky the other
important point is that the earth isn't
completely spherical
if the earth were really a completely
spherical object then you could actually
just
change its orientation and none of these
processional effects would occur where
does the bulge of the equator come from
the bulge at the equator comes from the
idea that this is rotating when i when i
lived in new york when i was a young lad
they used in italian restaurants get
bits of dough and stand in the window
and they'd twirl it around and throw it
up in the air and the more they threw it
up in the air the more it spread out
well here you've got the earth and it's
not a piece of pasta and you can't throw
up in the air nicely but if you were to
and it's spinning around fast enough you
can imagine that the sort of centrifugal
forces will pull it out at the equator
and squash it down top and bottom so
what actually happens is that the earth
instead of instead of actually tipping
up starts to process around so that the
the axis of the earth slowly moves
around
in sort of absolute coordinates but
because the forces involved were
actually very small
and the earth's mass is very large the
time scales are very long it processes
on a time scale of about 26 000 years
takes about 26 000 years for the earth's
axis to process around if it weren't
this squash sphere it would then rotate
and it would act as though all forces
acted in the middle and it's this small
non-spherical nature of the earth which
leads to this axial procession so
although in in qualitative terms to sort
of understand what these talks do and so
on is relatively straightforward uh the
mathematics is rather more complicated
and of course the other thing that
complicates things is in the solar
system for example um the earth and the
moon and the sun are not always in the
same orientation so sometimes you know
the earth's on one side side of the moon
and the sun's on the other side of the
of the earth so they're all you know
oriented different ways around sometimes
the sun and the moon are both on the
same sides of the earth so the even this
talk effect how the earth is being
tugged around changes with time
and that leads to a whole another thing
this whole thing called mutation which
is the sort of shorter term wiggle with
wobbles of the earth's axis on sort of
time scales of eight years that then
superimposed on this long time scale
twenty six thousand year effect